welcome to entrepreneurship thought
leaders are our series that we been
running every Wednesday afternoon for
years today we have a special guest we
have ed catmull from Pixar so he's the
president of Pixar and also the
president of Dixie Dixie I knew that it
is the animation Dixie's a little
different company and and what we're
here today is to talk about what Disney
does use a lot of cups Disney does use a
lot of cups they do I would imagine to
talk about his new book creativity
incorporated so Edie has in its and just
to give just a little by way of
introduction and also to give a plug I
really and I just said this to Tina
Seelig who's sitting over there
somewhere I really do think this is the
most useful and interesting creativity
book I've ever
I've ever read and note that I wrote one
so I'm like putting it might at a head
of one of my books and and the reason
it's so interesting in addition to the
fact that it's very well done and and
then ed and I were just talking about
the very compulsive process by which he
and his editors and went through to
makes a great book is there's kind of no
matching Ed's sort of life and in his
path which we're going to talk about of
course Pixar and then on top of that he
weaves together all these sort of ideas
about things that you can do to build a
more innovative and creative company so
that's what we're going to talk about
and use Pixar as the background just one
little comment that I thought was sort
of amusing I was lucky to be a want one
of among 40 people who were given an
early version of the book to read and
give comments and and this is sort of a
hint until I think Ed's personality and
style is that so
having being sort of like a management
person I've read and commented on a lot
of business books especially ones by
successful senior executives and after
reading the first the first draft of I
guess was the second draft one of my
comments to add was not enough
narcissism which I didn't think was ever
possible in in what I meant was I didn't
want him to be more of an egomaniac was
I wanted to hear more about
how he was feeling and thinking and what
his reasoning was and then just having
spent the last couple of days rereading
the book again he really has done a
magnificent job of bringing his
perspective without real narcissism it's
just your perspective so without further
ado let's start getting to questions so
in rereading the book one of the things
that still strikes me is that as a young
boy you were sort of fascinated with
Disney films but then you did this weird
thing you went off and went in another
direction and got a PhD in computer
science ad did an amazing thing this
hand was that your dissertation no as a
class project there's a class plot to
describe what the hand was oh well I buy
by chance I happen to be at the
foundation school for computer graphics
and I took a class and everybody was
supposed to make something and there's
some software they had not this time
everything was made out of polygons or
quadric services and that was it and
they didn't share enough promise and so
I thought what I would do is is digitize
my left hand so I made a plaster of
Paris mold of it and I learned later
that you should you just shave your hand
or put vaseline on the back and and then
I carefully digitized this and then I
made a little movie of it and it was
shown at the computer graph excuse me
the ACM conference because it wasn't a
SIGGRAPH at that time back in 1972 and
it was only those of us who actually
ignored the existing software and wrote
our own that stayed in computer graphics
huh so that's to me I think that story
sort of diagnostic and maybe we could
talk a little bit more about that I the
next thing I want to get to is is this
amazing experience you have at the New
York Institute of Technology but so
there's sort of your boyhood dream of
being sort of a graphics person and then
you kind of move into computer science
so maybe you talked a little bit about
how you thought about bringing those
things together and how that's sort of
affected what happens subsequently well
for the I I grew up in the 50s and so my
parents and I didn't know this
times we just growing up to say from
neighborhood it was only years later I
looked back and thought wow they just
went to Depression and World War two and
now we were in this bubble of the 50s
and the two iconic figures at that time
were Walt Disney and Albert Einstein so
I wanted to be an animator and I watched
Walt every Sunday and I explained things
and I read about it and did a lot of
crime came fairly good at drawing and I
liked math and physics and and when I
got out of high school I realized that I
had no idea what the path was to get to
be an animator because there were no
schools for it so I switched over into
physics and I got my undergraduate
degree in physics and I got a second
undergraduate degree in computer science
where I was going to study computer
languages at the time but I returned to
school and this during the height of the
Vietnam War so it was important to be in
school my draft number was thirty that
Mina probably doesn't mean much to
people nowadays but it meant an awful
lot then and I was at this great school
and when I took this course I recognized
that the the art and the technology side
could come together and while the images
were very crude at the time and there
was no way you could say this could go
on any entertainment thing there was the
potential error so I worked on solving
problems of trying to make it so that
the images looked good enough to go into
feature film and when I got my doctor's
degree I went out with the goal of
creating the first computer animated
film and my prediction at the time was
that it would take ten years for us to
solve the problems I was wrong it took
twenty sorry optimistic so in between I
mean one of the most amazing stories in
the books to me is you got this job
offer from this guy at the New York
Institute of Technology and I this
and maybe you shouldn't talk so the guys
name Alex sure that's it's not like sure
dr. Alex sure and and so one of my
favorite part you read this in the book
is that his word salad so he would say
things like our vision will speed up
time eventually eventually deleting it
things like this so this guy apparently
was quite a character so I should
describe a little bit about about like
this early sort of attempt I guess to
solve this problem sort of amazing well
you won't the the what was really cool
for me just coming out with this vision
was here was a man who ran this this
College on Long Island and he wanted to
be the new Walt Disney now he never said
he want to be the Walt Disney what he
said every day was he didn't want to be
the new Walt Disney but he he was
willing to fund it and at that time I
was in charge of this brand-new lab and
hiring people and Alvy Ray Smith who
graduate from here was actually my
second hire there and it was this
amazing opportunity and there was a man
that was willing to fund it but at that
time I did not want to be a manager so I
had some theories about how to manage so
that I could get some really good smart
people in there and and have them be so
highly self-motivated that I wouldn't
need to manage him and I could do my
interesting work and so five years later
I was hired away by George Lucas and
we'd had actually a pretty great group
and and had made a lot of right
decisions but I I remember at the time
looking back thinking okay when I came
here I had some ideas about how to
manage and one third of them were an
absolute crock I think just were bad
ideas or naive and 2/3 of the max who
were pretty good and I I felt going
forward into Lucasfilm now where there
was this an incredible opportunity that
the ratio would probably be the same and
the reason I say like one-third
two-thirds because I people have heard
that 8020 rule and
in 90/10 rule and actually I think the
problem is those kind of delude you
because they make you think you're
better than you are I think you're
better off saying you know I'm probably
wrong more than I think I am before
let's let's talk a little bit about the
Lucas days next and then on to sort of
Steve buying Pixar but one thing that
really strikes me struck me we're just
talking about a minute ago was how open
you were so so you did a whole bunch of
things that almost sound like modern
open source to to sort of build the
knowledge around making computer
animated films so so how did you come to
that decision and how did it help in the
like because I mean we look at how close
and how paranoid the companies are
including one Steve Jobs found it for
example but but it's sort of an
interesting decision that that that
entrepreneurs a lot of entrepreneurs in
the group would have to make whether to
be open or whether to be closed well I
came out of a university environment
which is very open and so I was inspired
by that and and I would say it was an it
and what at the time I knew it was an
extraordinary environment and the way
that we share things with each other so
it now came out with us this idea of
making a film and I wasn't the only one
around who wanted to do that and I was
aware because it was actually a really
small field we're talking about a
handful of people here and they wanted
to get there first they're very
competitive with their ideas and so they
did not want to share their discoveries
and at this time SIGGRAPH the computer
graphics community was brand new but my
belief at the time was that we were so
far away from what we needed that the
the the ideas of recurrent today would
get completely bypassed so we published
everything and the rationale was that if
we publish everything we're more likely
to attract the best people so we began
to accumulate people that aren't only
shared in the vision but they were very
good because they liked the idea of
sharing and
we we we were rewarded because then we
get these people but we were
participating in a bigger community and
today most of my friends are still in
this community and I really highly value
them when we get together all the time
and in in Steve never actually tried to
prevent us from doing it even when Steve
was there we always published and to
this day we still do in fact the last
couple years the papers coming out of
Disney and Pixar have been the single
biggest block of paper so many
institution so that open this despite
job this infamous sort of secrecy at
Apple he would he was okay with you
operate he never applied it to us that's
interesting he said to do it my way so
so let's move on and talk so you so you
mentioned you got hired by George Lucas
when when he was sort of at the height
of sort of early Star Wars fame tell us
a little bit about what you learned and
what happened in the early days with
Lucas and and then tell us about how you
almost got bought by General Motors
which is I think sort of an interesting
plot twist really surprised me when I
read it so George had just made Star
Wars 1977 and he was working on a second
film at Empire Strikes Back and he was
going to take a big risk with it because
as you know it ends with a cliffhanger
he believed that the technology of the
time is one of the things that helped
Star Wars stand apart I mean he
obviously believes in the story but he
had the best people working with Optima
can exceed for doing blue screen matting
and and and those kinds of things so he
was the only person in the industry that
was willing to fund bringing high
technology into film so he hired me to
bring in expertise in digital audio
video editing and computer graphics so
we then got together and I had learned
something about managers right I got
somebody over each group instead of
trying to have a flat structure got
anymore who came here from Stanford and
I'll be running the graphics and
guggenheim over video editing and we
just start plowing headed with full
support from george and it was exciting
it was rewarding
we were also off to the side that is
while they had these really good
filmmakers there it was clear to me that
what we were doing was was completely
and utterly irrelevant to what they were
doing but it's George's money and he
spent it the way he wanted so that was
kind of the the attitude so we're off to
the side busily doing things there and
and you know pretty good early sugar
daddies actually do look back pretty
good well that was that would actually I
count ARPA
now called DARPA as a person and an
ARPA's way of running at that time I
thought was enlightened I think they
went downhill after that nothing they're
back on on a better track but the but
their funding of of students across the
United States with very low bureaucracy
I believed was brilliant and at the time
I knew it's great that's right I loved
the model and then there was Alex Shore
as a sugar daddy but he he knew nothing
about filmmaking and then there was
George Lucas who had just made Star Wars
and then of course the next two were
phenomenal successes so it was an
amazing adventure with exciting people
and all these people it wasn't right
well in this case of George and his wife
got separated and George want to
maintain the control of the company so
she got the cast and he got the company
and so they were then cash-poor and at
that time it was the decision was made
to sell us we had built some hardware
that we had designed so we were gonna
use that as a basis for the business and
we brought in VCS and we put together a
fairly difficult deal to sell but in the
end it was Phillips Medical and General
Motors
who came through and were willing to buy
the company for fifteen million dollars
to George and give fifteen million
dollars to us to get us going and it was
within one week of signing when within
General Motors the eds part of the Ross
Perot holdovers and the cars people got
into a war with each other and it
brought all the deals to a halt and so
ours fell apart but but are you very
close
you were very but but what this wasn't
so they weren't a film company you were
selling a piece of computer hardware
right yes what was it what's called the
Pixar image computer it was made to
composite images together but as 4k
resolution films so very high resolution
really fast for that but it turns out
that it was also very good for image
processing so we had started company a
lot of orders from three-letter agencies
around Washington DC where we the box
would be delivered and we'd never hear
from them again and then in the medical
image industry where we did the first
volume imaging mm-hmm and and then we
entered into a contract with Disney to
color the cells so that Hardware we
built and we had to learn how to
manufacture so when Steve bought us I I
know the president I know nothing about
being the president of a company I don't
know anything about manufacturing or
sales or marketing and there wasn't
anybody in the group that did so so why
did Steve by you guys that's not exactly
an endorsement the last couple of
seconds well no actually I mean yeah I
know I the thing was Steve had worked
with consumer products before when he
network with a high-end product so he
had no instinct for the marketing
pricing selling or manufacturing of iron
product so basically none of us were but
but when he bought you was was he buying
a computer a hardware company or was he
buying a movie company I guess it's sort
of the question what do you think he was
buying well we were still years away
from it even being
practical okay so he was buying the
people okay now what happened was after
he we first met anyone he was Apple then
he disappeared for some strange reason
and then he which we we learnt about a
month later and then he reappeared and
he he wanted to buy us to use as the
foundation for this new computer company
so we declined so then he went a new
computer company was next yeah well he
then went got some people okay and and
that then became next okay and after he
formed next I ran into him at SIGGRAPH
which by coincidence was in San
Francisco so we walked the floor and he
still wanted to buy us as a group but
now it was to be what we want it to be
okay so we've been in negotiations which
yourself was an interesting long story
we won't go there but it resulted in him
acquiring us from so so far I don't see
much sign of an organizational strategy
are you somebody believes this is an
aside but it's really do you believe an
organizational strategy after going
through because we haven't gotten to the
story about how Pixar emerging became a
film company like what's your view of uh
sort of long-term planning an
organizational strategy well at the time
I didn't I mean the fact you know I was
reading a lot of books at Turner it out
but but I couldn't actually connect with
them it's like surfing you got to be the
right place to catch the wave well I was
never at the right place so you were
just tumbling around there in the ocean
but in terms of strategy we mean in one
sense you could say yes we had a
business plan and so forth but I believe
and I'd say this is very early on is
that for all the planning it's like when
the reality hits like I'm going to adapt
to the reality all right so those plans
quickly went out the window for a
variety of reasons either because we had
miss called it or or we didn't know we
were doing they just there a variety of
reasons there but but all cases where we
kept rethinking and trying to adapt to
what was there so you were they call it
started improvisation our colleague on
Kathy eisenhardt always talks about how
a lot of times it used to improvise and
respond to what's
front of you and the plan goes out the
window constantly so let's let's talk a
little bit about they're still doing it
you're still doing that yeah talk about
sort of the early days what did you do
before you became a film company because
there's a how many years from the time
that Steve bought you to the point where
you were sure you were a film company
because that went on for a while he
acquired us in in 86 the beginning of 86
and we entered into our contract with
Disney to make Toy Story in 91 okay all
right so that's the base that was five
years and in in the five years we had to
go from nothing to hiring the people
figuring out manufacturing which was an
intense and very educational experience
in a surprising way to me and I learned
something that which is just affected my
outlook but we we weren't big enough to
keep creating new hardware to actually
keep up with the way that was happening
in the whole industry as a whole and so
our business plan basically did not work
and then we had to figure out how to
gracefully get at it without screwing
our customers one of us got customers
was Disney and and I and I'm looking at
this saying okay while we're kind of
doing okay here I mean we're a little
underwater so that's kind of okay it's
not oh boy okay but you can see where it
was going it was going more underwater
so how do we get out from this and so a
guy called me and who's running some
other coming he was acquiring all of the
image processing companies figured that
if he got all the different products and
consulting the one company to have a
sustainable business so he called up and
said would you be willing to sell your
hardware business and I said well let me
think about it clicked
so calling back the next day and says
yeah we will do this and so we sold it
for a million dollars and the thing was
I knew that they would never pay the
million dollars and the reason we did it
was they would keep manufacturing the
box uh-huh for Disney
while we were rewriting the software to
go on to Silicon Graphics all right and
it turns out they did fine they lasted
for several years but ultimately which
we knew that they were doomed but it so
that's an argument for selling something
for nothing and it's still the right
thing to do it's sort of an interesting
well yeah we were trying to protect them
and yeah yeah and Steve was ok with that
because Steve tried to sell the by the
way Steve tried to sell the company to
Microsoft and suck on graphic sort of in
between and aeleus there so oh yeah so
that was it was it was a very unusual
time first of all we were losing a lot
of money and so by the time we were we
had done with us Steve was 54 million
dollars in the hole so that puts this in
an unusual circumstance because you
logically was before Steve Jobs was
really rich this was like a substantial
portion of his net worth at that time as
I understand it yeah I think the the the
biography said he was worth 100 million
dollars at the time which I don't think
was true I think was probably double
that but he never said hmm but fifty
four million dollars out of you know one
time is a significant job so it was very
difficult for him and he so he would
sell but what what he would do when he
would try to sell like to Microsoft he
would he asked for this number which is
outrageously high and they came back
with a really big number but it wasn't
the number he asked for so I'm thinking
well okay it's it's over with I know
it's too big of a hole for Steve so they
will compromise in the middle
Steve wouldn't compromise
and this happened three times so I
finally realized he's actually not
trying to sell us he's trying to
validate whether or not huh we're worth
something okay and as soon as somebody
says they're worth something well he's
not gonna let him have us so we you know
we dumped the heart of business we
started selling software we started
making commercials and because of our
one we had maintained a superb
relationship with Disney through all
this and because we had won awards with
were the shorts because we're John
directed these shorts and we're making
very good commercials that we we were in
a situation where Disney now having
these four remarkable films thought
there was a big appetite for animation
so they they took a gamble on Nightmare
Before Christmas and and I thought well
that's kind of idiosyncratic computer
graphics is probably just as weird as
stop-motion but you know we'll take a
gamble on it and the term they used it
it was it was boutique animation so we
entered into a the contract in 1991 to
make that story
yeah and that and that was your first
your first time so so when you were talk
a little bit about what you learned and
what what happened during the making of
the first Toy Story because I went here
Lewin about that and then and then one
thing that's sort of interesting that
I'd forgotten too until it just today
when I was rereading it that that Steve
decided to do the IPO before the gluten
came out was that correct yes so so sort
of amazing I mean so you still had made
no money at all here yes we made no
money so so this isn't the way it's
supposed to work they tell me in your
venture capital classes so it's sort of
an amazing story so and this is where I
you know where Steve was showing his
brilliance now around this time next is
kind of not working out so well and and
I've got a good relationship with Steve
but on all of this too but we didn't
want him there full
hi all right he was really good
part-time because he faced our dip and
he let us keep raining okay yeah so
we're trying to figure out how to make
this movie and we were a group though
that had been through failures together
so we'd all experienced that and it was
really difficult to figure this out and
we made a lot of miss estimates and the
first versions didn't work very well
but we as we got closer it became
apparent that we were onto something
really big and I have to say John
Lasseter believed i from the minute that
this is going to be gigantic but from
Disney's point of view it was a boutique
film so they didn't put any consumer
products behind it because they didn't
see it being anything but we got into
the last year it was now parent it was
it was big and so Steve said ok now we
are we are going to revolutionize this
industry but we're also in a position
where because we've got the experience
here not only do we have the first film
out we will probably have the second
film out before anybody else can get
into this but the deal that we had with
Disney frankly was not a very good deal
we got like three to five percent of the
profits or something like that so it was
not all that very good not very good so
so Steve called John and me together and
he said okay our deal lasts for three
pictures and the end were on our own
Michael Eisner will realize as soon as
this film is successful that he will
have just created his biggest nightmare
so he will not want the contract to end
so when the film comes out he will
renegotiate and when we renegotiate I
want 50% of the profits but if we get
50% of the profit
that means we have to put up 50% of the
money so in order for us to put a 50% of
the money we have to have the money in
the bank
therefore we should go public so John
are saying whoa whoa whoa whoa this is a
little early here let's prove our worth
first but Steve being Steve had a
compelling way about him so we put on
the roadshow we went out and showed
pieces of the movie but what he what
what he told me was went on the roadshow
so I went out with our CFO went with us
Lawrence Lee and Steve and as we went
out the argument was that the company
will go public one week after the movie
opens so you will see that we're
changing the industry and so that's the
prep so the movie comes out it opens
huge it gets incredible reviews and then
the next week we go public and it was
the biggest IPO of the year or it's
bigger than Netscape incredible there's
an incredible thing so so since you
mentioned Steve at some point we can get
this to one of my favorite parts of the
book is in and in the book at various
time touches so you worked with Steve 26
years you said yeah and and there's a
there's also a chapter at the end that's
specifically about Steve one of my
favorite parts was you describing how
you basically learn how to argue with
him without going crazy so so I thought
that was quite interesting maybe you
could describe a little bit about how
your relationship evolved and how you
learn - yes so as we started with Steve
Steve had a reputation which everybody
knows because it's part of the public
record people talk a lot about it and I
want to you know later address some of
that but I did ask Steve to begin with I
said so what happens or how do you work
if somebody doesn't agree with you and
he said well I just explained it to them
until you understand
so I go back to my colleagues and
explain this and they all have this
nervous laugh now I the thing you should
understand is in all the twenty years
were Steve Steve and I never had one of
these loud verbal arguments and it's not
in my nature to do that
so I never actually had an argument see
but we we did disagree fairly frequently
about things and the way it worked was I
discovered was that I would say send me
to him and he would immediately shoot it
down because he could think faster than
I could so yeah you know we end the
conversation and I would then wait a
week and you see the users on the
telephone I call him up and I'd give my
counter-argument to what he had said and
he'd immediately shoot it down so I'd
wait another week sometimes this went on
for months but in the end one of three
things happened about a third of the
time he said oh I get it you're right
and that was the end of it
and there's another third of the time of
which you say you know actually I think
he is right the other third of the time
where we didn't reach consensus he just
let me do it my way never say anything
more about it so that worked out that's
up but it's pretty interesting because I
mean I was really struck with that and I
don't think I have a lot of time to talk
about at the end but also you have an
argument that that especially later in
his life he sort of was was
misunderstood in terms of just the
negativity part glossed over the fact
that he got more mature and emotionally
sensitive but they yeah for me it was an
important thing is that is that you've
heard about Steve in us early days and
things and the way he interacted with
people and and I was there for that and
saw about as it applied in our
particular environment and I saw a lot
of cases where Steve overreached or like
he would go for a home run and he would
get the home run but like he would lose
the game and what people didn't
understand is Steve were so incredibly
smart that he was learning
those mistakes he was learning the
certain kinds of overreaching get in the
way and by the time we got to dealing
with Disney he was going for a 50/50
partnership the way he delivered hard
news changed with people and he became
an empathetic person and for the again
there were difficult decisions in the
way Steve deliver the news changed
dramatically basically most of the
people who saw this change in Steve then
stayed with him for the rest of his life
all right so that arc and Steve is
unreported and the reason it's missed is
like when reporters or anybody that's
gonna write about Steve calls to ask us
well Steele is still alive I'm not gonna
psychoanalyze Steve to us to a person I
don't know and none of these people
would so the change in Steve which to me
was very dramatic was it's not you know
publicly now and so that's well
described in the last and sort of the
addendum to the book or whatever so
we've got about 10 minutes before we
open up with the question what I'd like
to do now is we've sort of talked a lot
about what it took to sort of get to
Pixar kind of through the first film and
not in the IPO but a lot of the book and
to me some of those interesting parts of
the book are the way that Pixar operates
as a as a routinely creative
organization so maybe there's a couple
of different topics you could you could
discuss one is what's talk a little bit
the the brain trust because to me that's
a fascinating part of the film and think
a little bit about how that might apply
to other kinds of organizations - well
the the the brain trust something we we
happened on accidentally John was the
director and he had poor people around
him who were very focused and funny and
really driven and there and they were
passionate about the film itself so they
would have intense discussions but it
was never personal and they basically
went through three films together and
this was so successful that as other
people were coming up we would add them
to this thing and then I understand
start to call it the brain trust
so there was something about having
colleagues giving notes to each other
that worked really well so we tried to
apply the principle to other groups like
with our technical groups and and others
and we found that it didn't work as well
so then we had to go back and look at it
and say okay what's actually going on
here that's making this group work
better than just a collection of smart
people which is where a lot of people
have brain trust means oh you're smart
people together and you're when you
discuss it so that's not what I mean so
one of the things we realized is that
the brain trust had no authority they
could not tell the director what to do
so when somebody else was directing and
now John is a member of it he could not
tell them what to do I couldn't tell him
what to do Steve couldn't know what to
do
and the consequence of that is that the
director the person responsible was not
coming into the room in a defensive
posture knowing that this group could
screw them over alright so it changed
the dynamics but then we had to pay
attention to a lot of elements of the
dynamics because in our case we need a
lot of deep candor about what works and
what doesn't work and what we found in
this is true most places is there are
good reasons why most people hold back
and they don't say what they think they
don't want to embarrass themselves they
don't want to embarrass other people
they want to look good in front of other
people they might want to grandstand
there are all sorts of personal
emotional reasons that get in the way
frequently and most time I said they
won't admit that they're there so our
view was that as the managers was not to
actually examine the idea at the time he
was to sit back and examine the dynamics
of the room because if the dynamics were
working they're gonna solve the problem
so rather than me get caught up in the
problem and I wanted let's say okay I'll
say what they think and the result is
we've got this group which on the hall
has done
completely remarkable things every once
in a while it doesn't work it collapses
and every once in a while magic happens
but by setting it up and paying
attention to it we've got something
where on the whole it does it's had a
remarkable body of work yeah so so one
thing one of the things I do when I
teach is actually show a little film
that Brad Bird actually told me about
first it's it's the extra material the
Incredibles and it's it's his team sort
of fighting over various things and
really constructive conflict and when I
show it to executive audiences which I
do all the time they say that's great at
our organization that would never work
so the only it couldn't actually work
someplace other than Pixar okay so I
know I know we're out of time here
here's it we're there there that I have
a lot of views about it various things
from failure and risk and so forth and
and which I believe very strongly and I
can read the book if they want me at
read more so but with all that that that
theory I was also very aware that that I
am also subject to dilution just as
other people often can be there are so
we could be successful for reasons that
we don't see because we're all together
and we don't fully acknowledge what
somebody contributes but eight years ago
Disney came in and bought Pixar and at
that time they asked John and me to run
Disney animation so we made the decision
that we were going to keep these two
studios completely separate that is
they're not allowed to do any production
work for each other whatsoever so now we
had a group that was that was failing
and demoralized and led poorly so there
were these great films of the 90s their
basic it was for they were cultural
changing Little Mermaid allowed them to
bring the Beast and Lion King and then
it went downhill so we walk in and
basically the process people have taken
over and since the process is important
they're thinking about how lower costs
and get everything running smoothly and
so forth and they keep having bad film
after bad film so for us it's like quite
often you actually get a take
Boulton apply them to an entirely
different group of group of people and I
knew almost nobody there so we
determined to turn them around so we
worked with him we taught the principles
it took a while the fact is all the
stuff sounds good but like a lot of
things that sound good they depend upon
trust and Trust is something that takes
a while to earn and what and usually
what it means is you have to go through
some screw ups together and some
failures in mess ups and then still be
there for each other
and when you're there for each other
then you begin to trust each other and
then begin to apply the principles now
they've made six fellin since we've been
there all six have been critical
successes and we dramatically altered
everything from top to bottom and the
way they thought about it and the
principles in the philosophy and then
finally had the big commercial success
which was tangled which is the biggest
film since lion king then wreck-it Ralph
was a big success and then frozen just
became the highest-grossing animated
film in history alright so here's the
key thing it's largely the same people
who were there when they were failing
and the things that couldn't do and like
in terms of being honest or candid with
each other or figuring out how they
thought about problems and failures like
those same people learned those things
and they altered their behavior they are
a different group of people together and
and it's actually an amazing and
gratifying it is amazing and gratifying
and the other thing is like it has
because it kept them separate like
nobody can say like like they couldn't
say Pixar restaurant rescue them and
unlike wise did they didn't bail out
Pixar because we kept them separate but
they evolved into having very different
personalities the brain trust I just
have a completely completely different
mindset but that they're both
extraordinaire the best groups that I
know of and they're very different from
each other
so the brain trust at Disney is I recall
from the book there's a brain trust but
and you pulled out the people who
actually knew nothing about make
films for example that was one of the
kind of changes you make as I yeah we
got there they had above the director
they had three levels of people who were
giving mandatory notes none of them had
ever made a film before so once we that
so that's the first thing to go was like
your other director okay you're not
listening any other knows you don't have
to take our notes either and that was
rather shocking thing for them but we
had to go through some training so what
in fact what we did was we brought them
up to watch a Pixar session but we
didn't allow them to say anything it's
kind of strange really it was actually
very effective so the next day we all
went down and looked at a Disney movie
and our brain trust is they're watching
and they didn't say anything but the
brain trust there according to the
producer did the best notes they had
ever given that is just seeing how it
worked
altered their behavior so there's
there's a thousand things in the book
left we had about terrific minutes I
want to do a quick one and see we do it
quick and then I want to ask you the
Tina sealing question so so the the
quick one is my favorite chapter I
especially recommend it's got this kind
of weird name the hungry beasts and the
ugly baby so just to give us a little
taste can you give us just a minute or
two of what you mean by the hungry
beasts and the ugly baby that that
because I think it's essential for
managing innovation okay so it's a term
I heard use of Disney but it's using
other industries also and that is the
bulk of your people are working on your
your products it's a creative active
thing and it is where the it's the the
group that generates your revenue but
it's also where your costs are so I
don't mean it's the hungry beast in the
derogatory sense but it's like if this
piece it's gotta be fit or think like
the news or newspapers right you've got
to feed this thing so upfront we have to
generate new ideas what happens a lot of
companies is after the founders go away
or move on or get hit by cars whatever
happens to founders then they the most
organized people are the ones who run
the Beast so
put those people over the whole thing
and they bring the values to the upfront
process which is okay let's go on
schedule let's get this because we've
got to feed this this beast here our
issue and I think this is true in most
places is the very nature of what we're
doing at the front is fundamentally
different than we're running the Beast
we're doing something which is unknown
we're in the wild territory we don't
know what's going to happen and what we
first do or if I think of movies if
people think making the movie sounds
exciting and it is exciting but there's
an imagination of what it must be like
it's sorta like having this beautiful
baby and the baby grows up to be this
beautiful movie star but what do you do
if the baby is ugly
alright and that is our reality is that
the new ideas are fragile they don't
look good they take protection you
cannot judge them at that point you you
can see how well the team is working
together but you can't judge the ideas
now so we have to go from that stage to
somehow with engagement with that beast
and this is a long process but the
normal thing that happens is people
screw up the front end okay now that you
see like question and then get your
questions ready so so Tina where's Tina
I saw her somewhere
anyhow so no she's waited in the back so
Tina wrote a great book what I wish I
knew when I was 20 so I'm going to ask
you the Tina ceylon question so if you
could go back to your 20s you had quite
a bit of experience you think you're
sort of your early management sort of
jobs what advice would you give yourself
that you wish you knew then okay so this
is and I was asked this by a 20 year old
is this road trip here and I hadn't been
asking before so I here's the difficult
I've got is I've seen so many people who
incomes at various stages they believe
they need to know what's right and and
they can't listen to the advice so a lot
of you've heard of the term
cognitive bias confirmation bias or
confirmation bias confirmation bias
I think confirmation bias actually is
not strong enough of an implication of
what it is most of us have filters which
take the words that we hear and
frequently turn them into the opposite
of what they mean it's not even
selecting it actually is warping them
into something which is wrong so then
the question is okay could I have said
anything to myself at 20 years when I
was 20 that would have made a difference
and honest to god I don't know because I
sometimes talk with people and I tell
them things there and actually even with
the book I go through some examples in
the book of things which are thing
important where and and I'll say here's
something but the train of thought is
that that thing which I thought was
powerful I later learned meant nothing
okay so one of them is like that like
story is king like in our business
stories King and and and we believed
that we gave it to her or we said it but
then I realized that every studio said
that whether or not they were producing
works of art or complete utter pieces of
dreck alright so the phrase didn't
actually have any meaning so so so my
logic you didn't go to the next stage
after that but what I found was on a lot
of the websites people would refer to
that is I'll thank goodness you said
that because that's really what I
believe and and kind of missing the
deeper point is that sometimes those
things that are true don't actually
alter our behavior hmm and that's why I
find it really hard to say what would I
say to myself when I have the
opportunity to talk to some people and I
find that some get it and some don't so
the question is what am i the sort of
person who would have thought that okay
listen
well what to give some subtitles and
then we'll get to the questions Randi
comments are actually in ETL a few years
ago you can find the video basically
made the argument that it's that as
great as it would be to learn from other
people's failures they just don't have
the same emotional impact you got it
have your own failures - really new Ford
which is I think is sort of part of what
you're saying actually well it it is I
other than having lived this I don't
know what to do but I do believe that
along the way because of the mentors and
people I worked with there was a view
about mistakes and failure and trying
things which didn't for me
mm-hmm and and having that philosophical
view about how the world changes how you
know what interdependence actually means
and the full implication of that as well
as and this would be devices like the
first conclusions are almost always
wrong and so are the second the third
right and I and to this day we're still
finding things that we had concluded
long ago actually are incorrect in some
cases they were incorrect then and we
didn't realize it because we had
overcome it because of other means in
some cases they were correct then and
they are no longer murder Eric okay so
we've got ten minutes but we should move
to questions lots of hands here so yes I
guess I should repeat them because you
guys can have some yes created works
that then feedback to accelerate the
advances in technology computer graphics
in this case and I'm curious whether
it's getting any cheaper to establish
cycles like this between new
technologies and new kinds of creative
works or whether it's actually just more
and more expensive now well I basically
probably more expensive but but the one
thing to note about that is that the the
underlying technical base that is the
hardware continues to change the
underlying software base is changing in
our and our expert expertise level and
their workflows are changing
there is nothing stable about it and the
the reason you want to think about this
you know you know is this this loop
between the artistic and the technical
works I think it applies in a lot of
areas
is as a mechanism to deal through the
instability of that and that and that
instability is where we want to be hmm
all right someone else all the way in
the back yeah I like the back Yelp can
you speak a little bit about the balance
between the art the technology at Pixar
for example are there ever tensions or
conflicts between them would you ever
change the story to showcase the science
well no no the issue of showcasing the
science would actually never be a point
of conflict between the two for me the
issue is and I know this is true a lot
of companies because because companies
now are all realized and they have to
involve technology but for most people
are trying to bring it in a lot of them
they don't do it very successfully and
the for me the model is that you know
you're an integrated company if you
can't draw a line between the technical
and the creative okay all right and I
was saying Pixar and Disney is there is
no line between the two so that kind of
conflict actually if you're talking
about that within that that particular
comment wouldn't make any sense there
are people who are are pure technical
and people who are pure artists but then
they span this this range but whatever
we we work on and there there are
certainly disagreements about a variety
of things but it would never be about
showcasing technology over over the art
okay somebody right hand right there oh
something really important is that while
an organizational hierarchy might be
necessary it's good to avoid a
communication hierarchy but one of the
tricky things about this is you know
even if I'm in the mailroom at Pixar and
I know I could email you that doesn't
necessarily mean that I will so I'm
curious to know what other
manifestations there are what other
effects accrue after you've established
that there's no communication error well
okay so we we say this to all new
employees now the fact is because of
people's emotional responses then I know
full well that there are certain things
that I won't see or really won't say
things to me and I'll
to know that a manager to say it's some
level in the company has got objectives
and goals and and when you're in tight
budget or schedule which sort of the
reality of our lives at all times then
you will give off body language which
was that don't do anything to disrupt it
so while this is a principle to strive
for it's there are deep human personal
emotions which get in the way all the
time so the reason we're talking about
this is not to say oh what you're gonna
have is a structure free information
thing then ain't going to happen
all right but it means that you want
that because you need the truth to come
from anywhere and to be able to come out
of order so that means that you are
continually you've got a Sisyphean
something you say it I I can't say it
all right you you have this is the
Sisyphus task of continually rolling
this up there because there are always
the tendencies to go back in and to have
this the structure the communications
follow the organizational structure so
the the trick is to realize it's always
going on even if you're doing a pretty
good job of rooting it out it keeps
creeping back in it's an endless job all
right let's see oh well all the way in
the back with the head yeah have you
learned about humor and well the I mean
teamwork is one of those things every
scible likes you know it's good work in
teams the so I want to go beyond the
obvious is is to say that what we what
we learn to look for is just whether or
not that magic is happening in the team
like when the team is clicking together
and so we go through phases like you put
a group together it's good to have some
people have already worked together if
they've all worked together before then
actually you've got a close group which
is an open if there are too many new
people there they may go over the rails
so you actually want a balanced and new
people coming in that's alike that's
your upfront risk is how much new versus
experience do you have within a group
then you have to work things out there
and and sometimes the groups click and
they move along quite well but a lot of
times there are problems and you know
you've got this problem if is does if
there are problems do people to meet
there raise your hands have a problem
well it's kind of the responsibility for
the group to work things out and and and
they feel like it's going out of school
to go you know immediately up the ladder
to say there's a problem here but on the
other hand sometimes there really are
problems that will sink it so you've got
this fuzzy thing where problem should be
working on their group but sometimes
they're not so what you need are people
who are candid have enough experience to
say I want to raise the flag so it's not
blowing the whistle he's not calling it
at all it's just saying I think this
isn't working as well as it should so
you get a couple flags and say okay
let's try some tweaking so we will do
tweaking and most of the time the
tweaking which sometimes is adding a
person or taking a person out is enough
for the team to click into place
sometimes that doesn't work and then we
have massive failures and restarts so we
span the range there but the only time
we know is gonna work is when you
actually feel that team working together
right I fell all the way to the right
yeah yes they do you see this industry
in the next five to ten years well since
our films take five or six years to make
than the five year parts the easier one
we even have the scheduled out but when
I talk about the stability of it
obviously the the mechanisms for
distribution are changing there are
three different kinds of long format
storytelling there's always been very
good long-form television
there's the live-action model for making
films and then there's the model that we
use it Disney at Pixar and we're
embedded in an industry which is both
changing the way we deliver and because
it's going global means that there is a
we're bringing in connections with the
other parts of Disney in the outside
world
so it is trying to to make the
storytelling work so that's the changing
part the thing that still is the same is
the storytelling is not just
entertainment it is the way we
communicate with each other the way we
talk with our children we read to them
we tell stories we read stories in the
newspaper
we've got articles books storytelling is
our way of of teaching and talking with
each other so that's always going to be
there even though some of the form will
change so we're trying to be flexible
enough to adapt to the things that are
happening but believe we have a model
based upon a the way we as humans act
all right and last question yeah right
here what are you gonna wear spending
most of your time in the management
sector or the creative storytelling
animation where do you find yourself
enjoy well the first thing to know is is
for me managing is a creative act and I
define creativity to be very broad it
isn't just what some people think in
terms of the artistic side that it is
problem-solving and that our central
problem is to try to remove the barriers
to that and in addressing the barriers
and the blocks and things can get in the
way then one has to think about the
human nature that we've got and our
differences and things that happen you
know the people that are very difficult
for me to discern and I find that very
fascinating so that takes most of my
time so early in my career I was very
technically focused and now I'm very
focused on what I think is a complex
difficult problem and that is how how we
address these hidden problems to get in
our way of problem-solving alright so so
worth the just just a sort of closing
comment I think in ads answers you're
seeing that that you don't get glib
management consultant or PR person
responses he thinks very deeply about
the stuff that he does much more deeply
frankly than most business people are
consulting people I know and and and
that's one reason that I found the book
so fascinating from the very beginning
because it really does reflect the sort
of deep thought that that you've seen
from Ed here so thank you so much for
joining us ed and
you